[Music]
cartoon characters are some of the most
recognizable figures in the modern world
but not all of them are beloved we're
about to list the 10 most annoying stay
tuned to the end to find out which of
these characters blew up the moon just
to be annoying don't forget to hit that
subscribe button if this is your first
time visiting the things and to give
this video a big thumbs up let's jump
right into 10 annoying cartoon
characters that everyone hates several
characters on the loud house the loud
house is a huge smash hit fans have
taken the internet by storm to voice
their opinions on the show and its
characters it doesn't take much digging
and to find out some characters are just
not everyone's cup of tea melodramatic
cold and selfish that's how many
describe the mopey Lucy valve but Lucy
isn't the only annoying loud sister 17
year old Laurie loud is just as bad the
eldest of the loud siblings is
characterized as bossy selfish and
oblivious as you may imagine when Laurie
bothers to address one of her siblings
it's usually in a rude big sister type
of way that can get old pretty fast at
some point the fans have criticized most
every loud sister for their behavior
toward Lincoln who seems to be bullied
the most in the house come to think of
it even Lincoln got a few critiques for
his underwhelming personality traits
compared to his sister's and then
there's Clyde in his weird obsession
with Laurie many fans can't seem to get
on board with that either but
interestingly enough putting all these
flawed characters together actually ends
up creating the best Nickelodeon show
ever the loud house wouldn't be the same
without them
DeeDee Dexter's Laboratory is a classic
cartoon and widely loved everyone loves
Dexter's fun inventions and quirky
dialogue one thing many fans seem to
agree on is that DeeDee is annoying
if one BuzzFeed contributor even called
her the most annoying sister in
television history
DeeDee seemed well-meaning and just
wanted to spend time with her beloved
brother best intentions aside DeeDee
often frustrated Dexter to the point of
rage poor Dexter would be in deep
thought or busy at work on an invention
and didi would pop up to distract him no
one likes to be interrupted while
they're working some fans find didi
implausibly annoying theories have
evolved to explain her absurd effort to
obstruct Dexter's work some speculate
that didi is a time traveler intent on
preventing one of Dexter's inventions
could that be why she is so often heard
asking what does this button do is didi
secretly Dexter's daughter from a doomed
future when that theory is a little out
there but this one is more practical
maybe didi loves her brother and wants
to share her misguided enthusiasm with
him whatever her motivation is it's
clear Dexter agrees with those who find
his sister unbearable DW Reed we all
know Arthur the Beast speckled aardvark
who loves to read as much as Arthur and
Bucky our beloved icons little sister DW
seems to catch a lot of hate some fans
think DW is rude to her brother she
often makes fun of its glasses and
vision DW doesn't share her brother's
love of academia she's more interested
in materialistic pursuits the middle
read child loves her allowance and
bragging to her friends her poor social
skills maybe one reason that fans find
her so irritating when she's not making
fun of Arthur she's fibbing to her
friends DW is prone to exaggeration and
gets carried away with pretend play
several episodes of Arthur center around
DW sli's coming back to haunt her no one
likes a fibber and constant
exaggerations can be tiresome DW has her
positive traits she loves her older
brother even if she gives him a hard
time being a middle child is tough DW
may be so annoying to get attention away
from cute baby Rosie or her brainy older
brother tantrums are part of childhood
and DW is no exception she seems to lose
her temper often her bad reputation
aside it just wouldn't be Arthur without
DW pearl crabs constant emotional
outbursts get on anyone's nerves no one
likes a melodramatic overreaction
predators have taken note of both of
these
behaviors in pearl crabs she's the
daughter of Krusty Krab owner mr. Krabs
and she spoiled entitled and
self-centered pearl can't seem to keep
her emotions in check much like her
anger prone father any time pearl is on
screen you can make a safe bet that
tears are in her future everything makes
her cry from the truly sad to the
mundane pearl can't seem to understand
why anyone wouldn't want to be around
her when her prom date stood her up she
fluttered her dad's apartment with her
tears
maybe her overreactions are what drove
him away it's no wonder pearl is so
spoiled and irritating her father's
obsessed with money and materialism
pearl never stood a chance growing up
around that kind of ever ice mr. crab
seems to flip between spoiling his
daughter to keep her from crying and
being stingy with her too as well
pearl probably grew up learning that
money is the purest form of affection
this would explain her shallow
personality and fragile emotions after
all her father is known to go into a
rage at the drop of a hat
Brobee yo gabba gabba is a cultural
phenomenon this show was created by
members of the band The Aquabats and is
truly the new experienced and family
entertainment
Brobee is a green-striped creature who
always seems to be upset
Brobee spends most of his time moping
around and frowning on the rare occasion
that he's not sad or complaining he's
flailing around out of control he seems
to have very little rhythm for someone
who lives in a boom box and hangs out
with a DJ this big green goof may be
charming to some but his constant mood
swings are very heavy-handed Brobee
suffers from a defeatist attitude he
assumes he can't do things without even
making an attempt few things are as
annoying as a person throwing a tantrum
especially before they've even tried
he's frequently heard lamenting that he
just can't do things because he's too
little
Brobee sends a negative message that
younger people aren't capable and should
give up before they try the other
characters always have to convince him
to put in his best effort no one likes a
whiner and Brobee is a professional
complainer everything is too hard for a
long arms character Roby's negative
attitude constant
claiming and wild flailing outbursts
make him a truly annoying character
Squidward
chances are if you ask anyone who the
grumpiest octopus is they'll answer
Squidward fans of Spongebob Squarepants
have found his perpetual negativity
annoying for years Squidward has a
pretty good life he has a beautiful home
a stable job and very friendly neighbors
so why such a long face spongebob is
often cited as being the most annoying
character on his namesake show his
high-pitched and repetitive laugh can be
really grating irritating laugh or no
spongebob is just trying to be a nice
guy
Squidward meets his neighbors gestures
of friendship and cynicism and
resentment at every turn maybe if he
learned to accept love and friendship he
wouldn't be so angry all the time
it seems Squidward suffers from a real
lack of gratitude he complains about his
job and isn't thankful to be employed he
complains about spongebob and doesn't
see that he has a loyal friend this
eight-legged curmudgeon should spend
more time appreciating what he has in
less time being rude to his neighbors
and coworkers Squidward has even gone so
far as to file a restraining order
against his yellow neighbor that's
taking it a little bit too far SpongeBob
and Squidward are both employed at the
Krusty Krab and have to spend time
together making the restraining order a
bit impractical Caillou
whining pouting and selfishness these
are the traits the Huffington Post
attributes to Caillou Caillou is about
four years old in the show but seems to
bounce around in his development one
moment walking seems to be a challenge
but the next he's bounding a hey Belle
Caillou just can make up his mind
the Canadian toddler isn't an only child
in the show
Caillou often finds himself having to
play nicely and share things with his
younger sister Rosie it's not uncommon
for him to be heard whining that he
simply doesn't want to be nice to his
sister sharing is hard and Caillou just
isn't interested there is nothing he
can't throw a tantrum about every
episode includes
at least one meltdown over something
minor asking questions is an important
part of learning I went to riding the
car to mommy let's go
it's normal for kids Caillou's age to
ask questions all the time
Caillou seems to ask non-stop questions
about things he understands well when
he's not throwing tantrums being rude to
Rosie or pestering his parents he sets
his sights on the family cats hi you
often forces the poor pet to play with
him
scrappy-doo everyone loves puppies
unless that puppy is scrappy-doo scrappy
is the rambunctious nephew of
crime-solving Great Dane scooby Doo way
back in the 1970s scooby-doo was a huge
hit it was one of the most popular
cartoons on television the show enjoyed
years of prosperity until the ratings
dipped in 1979 the creators made an
attempt to pool the higher ratings and
new viewers by introducing scrappy-doo
many would look back on this as a
mistake
scrappy is a two-dimensional character
without much backstory the details of
where he came from and who his parents
are seemed to vary from season to season
scrappy is not a very well-behaved
nephew he often disobeys Scooby when
told to stay behind
scrappy insists on fighting every
monster all by himself and just won't
stay out of trouble while scrappy runs
his poor uncle ragged he spreads his
sassy attitude viewers didn't appreciate
the rude little dog and he stopped
appearing in the cartoon in the late 80s
his reputation was so strong that he was
later written as the primary villain in
the first live-action film
Peppa Pig Peppa Pig is a global hit with
episodes translated into over 20
languages
Peppa can now be seen all over the globe
people spend hours talking about Peppa's
annoying piggy grunts but those are
nothing compared with her rude behavior
Peppa just can't seem to be polite even
to her own father daddy pig seems to be
the butt of many of his daughter's jokes
you have to exercise every day from his
alleged unintelligence to his big belly
nothing is off-limits to Peppa when
she's not making fun of her father's
weight pemmican be found making her
younger brother George cry
Peppa excludes George from playing with
her and tells him he's too little to do
anything
poor George never gets a chance with a
big sister like Peppa Peppa's rudeness
doesn't stop with her own family she's
rude to her friends too Peppa can't
stand to lose any game and all the wall
whining incessantly if she doesn't win
she especially can't stand to see her
friends win
Peppa doesn't stop there she frequently
hangs up on her friends while chatting
on the phone with no warning
Peppa truly is a sore loser and will
make fun of anyone she sees as more
intelligent parents everywhere say Peppa
is a bad influence starfire Teen Titans
go has had a rocky reception since his
debut some accused the show of having
too little continuity with Teen Titans
as the lukewarm reaction of fans many
suggests the show is full of annoying
characters their worst of these is
perhaps Starfire the orange alien has a
loose grip on grammar that many fans
finds irritating being bilingual isn't
easy but Starfire has the habit of
peppering her sentences with unnecessary
buzz on top of adding the to every other
phrase
she also giggles non-stop that
high-pitched and incessant giggle is
enough to make anyone change the channel
it's no wonder so many have taken to the
Internet to voice their irritation when
she isn't snickering herself in the fits
Starfire flies off the handle of her
small issues she's prone to emotional
outbursts and
frequently destroys whole areas when
she's upset unpredictable and
destructive tantrums make her not only
annoying but done right dangerous what
if I did something to make you hate me
there's nothing you could do to make me
hate you
Starfire went so far as to blow up the
moon just to bother Robin for some
reason Robin still thinks she's amazing
he spends countless hours trying to
impress her and to win her affections it
goes to show you there really is someone
for everyone even the most annoying
character on Teen Titans go we hope you
enjoyed these 10 annoying cartoon
characters thanks for watching we'll see
you next time on the things
[Music]